but they're going to keep using this
they're going to use the capitol hill
riot
as the excuse to shut us all up and
you're going to have squishy fake
republicans
guys like mitt romney or arnold
schwarzenegger come out remember arnold
schwarzenegger was governor of
california
he was basically governed like a
democrat he wasn't wasn't particularly
strong
they're going to come out and use any
manner of hyperbole
to cram this narrative down our throats
schwarzenegger just came out he posted a
video comparing the capitol hill riot
to the nazis in kristallnacht
i grew up in austria i'm very aware of
kristallnacht
or the night of broken glass it was a
night of rampage against the jews
carried
out in 1938 by the nazi equivalent
of the proud boys wednesday was the day
of broken glass right here in the united
states
the broken glass was in the windows of
the united states capital
but the mob did not just shatter the
windows of the capital
they shattered the ideals we took for
granted
they did not just break down the doors
of the building that housed
american democracy they trampled the
very principles in which
our country was founded
is that so arnold
last i checked during crystal knocked
rioters destroyed 267 synagogues
throughout germany austria and the
sudetenland
they murdered at least 91 jews very
likely
many more 7 000 jewish businesses were
damaged
or destroyed and 30 000 jewish men were
arrested
and sent to concentration camps
and during the capital hill riot one of
the pro-trump
rioters ashley babbitt was shot and
killed by police
and a police officer sadly died
and a
rioter took took photos messing up nancy
pelosi's
office and some other fellow
took a podium and posed for funny
pictures with a podium
both bad things not saying that either
of those events were
crystal knocked or the capital right i'm
not not defending either either of those
events
not on the same level very different
torching hundreds of synagogues uh
deporting
tens of thousands of people killing lots
and lots of people
damaging 7000 businesses different very
different
not every bad thing is the holocaust
this should be emblazoned on
every debate stage uh
on on every camera that films a
political commentator
or a politician i wish people would take
this to heart
not every bad thing is the holocaust
idiots compare
bad things to the holocaust all the time
because they don't have any other
historical perspective
so the two the two things you'll hear
everything is either the holocaust or
the fall of rome
i suppose some things are like the
holocaust in the fall of rome in some
ways
but very few there are other historical
events
and you know schwarzenegger was not
alone
in in this kind of hyperbole aoc
everyone's favorite darling socialist
congresswoman
went on television and said look you
think
that you know it was a demonstrator who
died and then a police officer died
later from wounds and apparently some
other medical condition but it's sort of
unclear
no wasn't that and then i think three
other people just like happened to be
around the
protest and had heart attacks things
like that obviously not from the
violence
uh but regardless say i don't know five
five people
four of whom were demonstrators three of
whom
then died from their own medical
emergencies okay
very very sad right
aoc took that and somehow read that as
uh nearly half of congress almost dying
well you know i absolutely believe that
impeachment should be scheduled for
several reasons
several reasons one of course our main
priority is to ensure the removal
of donald trump as president of the
united states every minute and every
hour that he is in office
represents a clear and present danger
not just to
the united states congress but frankly
to the country but in addition to
removal
we're also talking about complete
barring
of the president or rather of donald
trump from running for office
ever again and in addition to that the
potential
ability to prevent pardoning himself
from
those uh charges that he was impeached
for
we came close to half of the house
nearly dying
on wednesday i don't
think that we did i don't
i don't think nearly half of the house
almost died uh i don't think
nearly any member of the house almost
died i don't think any member of the
house
was even injured that's just
a complete lie it's just completely made
up
why does aoc aoc is very good at this
you might call it the big lie she aoc is
very good
that's a phrase by the way that you're
going to be hearing a lot of left
wingers now referring to
like for instance because joe biden has
been comparing republican politicians
to joseph goebbels because joe biden is
a liar and an idiot
and a cynic and a hack and a very very
very bad man and so they're gonna
they're all gonna call everyone nazis
and then aoc is going to come out and
lie and say oh half the members of
congress almost died
not uh none of them the
the last time that members of congress
almost died like that
was not the capitol hill riot it was
2017
when a bernie bro shot up the
congressional baseball game and very
nearly killed steve scalise
and other members of congress steve
scalise really was close to death but
other guys
rand paul was hiding out right rand paul
could have been hit
other people too that that story
disappeared from the news
you didn't hear about the nazi democrats
and
all these sorts of things because that
was not
helpful to their narrative so even
though the congressional baseball game
shooting
was much much much much much more
dangerous to members of congress
that one disappeared and you didn't see
the hand-wringing
and all of these sorts of uh hysterical
calls
for for instance the impeachment of the
president if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there
[Music]
you